The underfunding of
schools in Los Angeles,
California
South Mississippi.
Minnesota,
North Carolina,
Missouri,
Washington, D.C.
The underfunding of schools in New
Mexico is devastating to our
children.
I don't know about you, but when I
hear the phrase "the underfunding of
school," my head and my wallet
explode.
Tax revenue per student in public
K-12 schools is up 24
percent nationally over the past two
decades, and that takes inflation
into account.
In New York, where I live, real
per pupil revenue has increased
by a mind boggling 68
percent over that same period.
The public schools here are now
shelling out more than $30'000
per kid, or more than double
the national average.
And that doesn't even include
the $16 billion extra that
New York's system got in federal and
state funding for COVID 19 relief.
Yet New York's public schools are
still as terrible as the Mets, the
Jets and the Giants, with only
a third or fewer of students up
to grade level in eighth grade
reading and math, according to
their scores on a nationwide
test, that's the gold standard for
measuring performance.
30 grand a year puts the
lie to the argument pushed by
unions and progressive advocates
that more money will fix schools.
More money hasn't helped the rest of
the country boost their scores,
either. None of this is a mystery.
The connection between bigger
spending and better outcomes is weak
at best and nonexistent at
worst. Certainly, the new money
in New York hasn't gone to
fundamentally reform what
gets taught or how or under
what circumstances.
According to a report by my
colleagues at the Reason Foundation,
teacher compensation is way up in
New York, especially when it comes
to health insurance and pensions,
which have grown by 147
percent. Nationwide, a dozen
states increase spending on teachers
benefits by over 100 percent,
and only three states kept the
increase below 10 percent.
Costs for things like
administration, support staff and
transportation are up 24
percent.
Dumping more money into a broken
system is like trying
to fix a leaky pipe by pouring more
water into it.
What needs to happen is a revolution
in how education is conceived
and delivered.
Over the past 20 years, New York has
allowed publicly funded charter
schools, which must attract and keep
students in order to stay in
business. The best charters have
waitlists, even though they get less
money than traditional public
schools. But like most places,
New York caps the number of
charters, and it doesn't even allow
education savings accounts,
tax credit scholarships and vouchers
that would allow more families to
escape traditional public schools.
Increasing the amount and variety of
school choice, though, is exactly
what New York and the country need
to be doing.
We're not going to seriously improve
educational outcomes for our kids
if we don't fundamentally change how
we educate them.
When you look back 20 years,
virtually every other service in
our lives, from coffee drinks,
to media to medicine, has gone
through multiple revolutions.
Everything is more geared toward the
individual.
It's more responsive and not just
cheaper in real terms, but better
too. K-12 education
is still basically the same as it
was when today's parents were
in school. The only difference is
the price tag, which just keeps
going up and up.